okay today I'm going to talk to you
about weight and mass now these two
things are very closely related but
there's a big difference between them
people often use them interchangeably
but there is a difference and that is
what we're going to be learning today so
first of all let's think about mass
let's imagine we have this person here
their mass is 75 kilograms now there's a
couple of key information bits of
information we need to know about mass
so first of all mass is a scalar
quantity
it just has a size not a direction as
well and the other thing is basic what
mass means is the matter that this
person or this I this object is made
from so that kind of atoms in their body
the matter that makes them up is 75
kilograms so let's imagine that we took
this person and they went and they went
to the moon so this is now this person
on the moon their mass would still be
exactly the same 75 kilograms because
the amount of atoms in their body the
matter in their body has not changed
they're still the same but they're just
on a different in a different place in
the universe so you'll see in a minute
why use this example of being on the
moon okay so what exactly is weight now
weight is different weight is a force
because this person on earth their mass
is 75 kilograms but their weight we need
to factor in the gravitational field
strength the gravitational pull of the
earth pulling them down so as a result
weight is said to be a vector quantity
it has both the size and a direction
because it's the size the mass and the
direction the direction of gravity
pulling them down so it's the effect of
the gravitational field strength but
acting on this person's mass so let's
kind of follow the same example as we
did before let's have a quick look to
see how this person's weight would
change this time if they weren't from
earth to the moon
now this person's weight on earth is 750
Newtons and I'll show you why that is in
just a minute now when they went to the
moon
the moon actually has a lower
gravitational field strength than the
earth so as a result the force pulling
them down towards the surface of the
Moon is going to be less so as a result
as they go to the moon when they go to
the moon their weight will decrease
their weight will decrease that is
because of the there's less force
gravitational field strength pulling
them down towards the surface of the
Moon please notice that weight is
measured in Newtons because it's a force
and force is measured in Newtons okay so
what we're gonna do now is we're going
to look at the equation behind weight
mass and gravitational field strength
and here it is right here so someone's
weight equals their mass so remember
that's like the matter within their body
multiplied by the gravitational field
strength so the strength of gravity on
that particular part of the universe so
it can be summed up with this equation
triangle right here weight equals mass
times gravity so let's see how this
equation relates to this particular
situation so the the first example here
now the reason why we got this here is
because of this on earth on earth we
always take the gravitational field
strength to be 10 Newton's per kilogram
this is a number that you need to know
so 10 newt's per kilogram so looking at
equation if I wanted to find the weight
I need to do the mass of this individual
multiplied by the gravitational field
strength so this person's mass was 75
kilograms and the gravitational field
strength is 10 Newton's per kilogram 75
times 10 is 750 Newtons
so that's how I knew this person's
weight however this person has then gone
to the moon now the gravitational field
strength on the moon is much less so on
the moon
the gravitational field strength is
around 1.6 Newton's per kilogram you do
not need to know this off by heart so
again let's have a look at our equation
to find the person's weight we do their
mass multiplied by their gravitational
field string so their mass is still 75
remember because the particles in them
no matter has not changed even though
they've gone to the moon that is the
same it's still 75 kilograms what has
changed is to gravitate the strength of
the gravitational field strength so this
time it's only 1.6 Newton's per kilogram
so let's quickly put that into the
calculator 75 times 1.6 equals a hundred
and 20 so their weight has dramatically
decreased to 120 Newton's so that is the
difference between weight and mass
remember mass is a scalar quantity it's
the matter in your body it's the same no
matter where you are in the universe
your weight is a force it's a vector
quantity and it's measured in Newtons
your your weight changes depending upon
the gravitational field strength and
finally this is the equation we need to
know weight equals mass times
gravitational field strength and here's
the equation triangle to support us with
that thank you